joining us here on the rich eisen show
courtesy of
our social media grand maester as he
cares to be known t.j jefferson at
2jiggy for those who care to follow our
social media ground
uh you've known this uh gent for quite
some time we're thrilled to have here on
the rich eyes and show this is what we
call
um you know high quality booking not
just because of who he is and
what day it is it's the 18th anniversary
of punk making its debut on mtv
but we're kind of stepping in it there's
big bears news and he's a big bears fan
ashton kutcher here on the rich eisen
show how are you sir
i am delightful how are you i am better
for talking to you all right screw it
give me your favorite tj jefferson story
let's just jump in let's just jump right
in what do you got for me
oh man oh man you know what the thing is
is that
that um
boy so i i i have to think long and hard
about this because
tj has so much compromi on me
what is this photograph we're seeing
right here let's help out as you know
it's you and him in a pool and
how old is this photograph that we're
looking at right here that that picture
is from
july the third 3rd 2001. damn we uh
we had just moved he and i used to be
roommates we didn't we never said that
and uh
he bought that house he was look you
know he was nice enough to allow me to
live there with him
and uh we moved in the first day of july
and we decided everyone would have a
fourth of july party
so why don't we have a third of july
party and
and this is the photograph we're seeing
huh on the screen here
it must be i can't see the photo but
right i'm assuming that it is it is that
yes it is
you can take the trust so okay i'll give
you i'll give you i'll give you a great
uh tj jeff you don't have to by the way
oh no he doesn't please turn his
microphone off
this is this is a quality one this is a
i'll put a little shine on you
okay uh so so you know
tj and i tj was like
we worked together for a while and
started traveling around the world and
doing various things
when i i would go on promotional tours
for various films and things
and at one point we ended up in
australia um
and and i i think i had to work the next
day or something and tj was like i'm
gonna go out
and so he comes out to a
nightclub um and basically gets kicked
out
because the bouncer at the at the
nightclub
thought that his altoids were drugs
they'd never seen altoids before
and so they they kicked him out
um and because the guy looked at his
like can of altoids and thought like tk
was like drug dealing inside of his
nightclub
and all you wanted was fresh breath just
in case you met someone at the club
trying to talk to this sheila as they
call them down there
and uh yeah so more things change the
more they stay the same
basically what you're saying 20 21.
ashton kutcher here on the rich eisen
show
18 years ago punk'd debuted
tonight uh ashton how did that show come
about
for you where where did that one come
from all those years ago
so when i was growing up there there
were these uh
audio tapes that you could get
of these guys the jerky boys of course
and
then the jerky boys would like call and
prank phone call people
and they would play these characters in
in their prank phone calls
and i just thought it was the funniest
thing uh when i was
when i was younger um i still think it's
really funny
um but with through a slightly different
lens today
but i always thought that that was that
was the funniest thing i
and and i watched candid camera and
things like that but i felt like candid
camera
never quite took it far enough yeah and
it and it just didn't have like the edge
of like the jerky boys that would
they they would go all the way there um
and so that's that's really where i and
i started batting back and forth with my
producing partner at the time this idea
of like can we make a show that's like
jerky boys and none of my representation
wanted me to do it
and they were like you know you're an
actor you're not gonna be seen as a
serious actor
if you go and do a reality show and i
was like
now i want to make this and i want to do
this and and i was doing the 70s show at
the time
and and shooting some films and
uh and i was like no i'm going to do it
i want to do it on mtv
and then i got the mtv and they're like
okay we will do the show but you've got
it
you've got to pull the pranks on
celebrities and i was like all right
uh and that's that's that's sort of how
it came to be so when you're saying
you didn't think uh candid camera
committed or to the bit or committed to
the prank
uh far enough are you referring to
making justin timberlake think his
home was being repoed by the irs for
instance that sort of thing
yeah yeah that sort of thing like like
making beyonce think that she ruined
christmas uh because
she dropped the tree that was like you
know the ceremonial christmas tree in
the middle of
you know century city um like having
having undercover agents come and bust
the gambling ring
uh and like bust through windows like
that kind of thing
so which celebrity was the most upset
or by being punked ashton i imagine when
it was first starting they had probably
been like what gives and then
obviously when the phrase even got out
there that people
you know pulling pranks in just everyday
life the word punking somebody to this
day still
even exists before you reach that i
imagine or even when you did reach that
sort of status
which celebrity got the most upset with
you
i mean i think the celebrity that's most
upset is me because i don't own this
show
you've been punked
i wasn't i wasn't wise enough back then
to know that i should own it um
but i think you know the people that
took it
that had the hardest time with it were
comedians
um which is interesting you'd think that
they would love it
um but i but comedians like to be in
control of the
joke they don't want the joke to be on
them unless they're making the joke
about themselves and so oftentimes we
would do a punk on a comedian
and they would get really um
they just wouldn't be happy about it um
and then there were a couple instances
where like you know like i think a-rod
was in the middle of like a trade
deal and he was talking about it with
friends
and that was on camera and he's like nah
you gotta burn the tapes
um and then there was one
where somebody pulled out a gun whoa uh
huh no i'm just listening i'm like whoa
somebody pulled out a gun huh
yeah somebody pulled out a firearm in
the middle of it and it got a little
got a little heated um
but you know at the end everybody was
cool with it i don't think anybody holds
a grudge
uh on it i think it's just in in that
moment
um people would get pretty upset that
you know like zach graf like beat up a
kid it was like people got upset
he beat up a kid he he literally beat
somebody
up because he was trump there was like
we
we had a kid that he wasn't a kid but he
looked like he was a kid
yeah and he was like spray painting his
porsche
uh in a parking lot and he just started
like
he started getting physical with him uh
and we had to go
we had to go calm that down yeah you got
to tap that one out because it
okay so at some point a line gets
crossed and so you're saying ashton
kutcher that a-rod was caught on tape
talking about
inside uh baseball stuff literally and
thus
when the punking was revealed he's like
yeah you're you're not airing that
did anything air from him or didn't no
no we we literally we we pulled the film
and destroyed it in front of them
because that was the thing about the
show which is um
unlike a lot of the other shows that are
out there
we every single person who was ever on
talked signed a release yeah that said
it's okay to air this right like we
didn't air
anything of anyone without their
permission
and and you know it seems that line has
been crossed nowadays but back then that
that that was the deal
and and we you know we honored that like
if if we got to the end of it and
someone was like
no not cool we're not aaron you can't
air it
we didn't and in that case he he made us
destroy
the um destroy the tapes ashton cut you
here on the rich eisen show you think it
could be done today i mean social media
being what it is it could be shared left
and right up and down you know that
you're
you're the first guy first individual to
get a million folks on twitter
that by the way was 12 years ago um do
you think this could be done again
rebooted ashton
yeah with the right with the right
people it could get done again i
actually think the interesting way to do
it would be um
do it through like nfps um and like
actually shoot a punk and make make
the prank itself uh in the video and nft
where there was a royalty right where
the person
who got pranked actually owned a piece
of it for perpetuity and then people
could
buy it sell it trade it well let's pitch
that out um me you
tj let's see put that thing together
let's uh let's pitch that out uh ashton
hey rich you know one thing
you were talking about people getting
mad there was one time when you know
because
punk got to be so big yeah that you know
at the beginning ashton was there for
all of them but then as his career took
off and he had to do 70 show and movies
it was like well if we wanted to get
rich and mike and chris were helping set
us up
and we could only get you at this time
in this date if you couldn't be there
we still have to do it like this has to
go on right
so the rock we're punking the rock
he's shooting the movie be cool the
director f gary gray is the accomplice
right so
ashton's not there he's doing a night
shoot so
jason goldberg and i were running the
plunk that day
and we blew up the rocks trailer like
his trailer for the movie
got blown up and
as the reveal starts to come you know
we had our two phil agents whitney
cummings was one and
vince greene was another and they're
kind of poking at the rock like
well it's kind of your fault i asked you
about
like plugging in an iron and like
they're
basically insinuating it is it's his
fault and he's being cool but you could
see
the rock is starting to now get more and
more upset he's cooking everybody's
pointing at him and saying this is your
fault
he's talking about his lava lavas which
are a samoan rap that he would wear
yeah and finally our guy vince who was
really good at agitating people said
something to him and the rock kind of
like made a move towards them
and everybody swarmed and then f gary
gray had to jump in and go
hey guess what you've been punked and
like you could see the rock like
seething and it literally was about 10
seconds where he went from
100 mad to he calmed down okay and then
i had met him before so i was like the
first person from production
who went up to approach him and be like
hey bro
everything cool right and i was a little
bit worried about that one but that one
you know ashley wasn't there for that
one and it was like you got a report on
that i'm sure ashton by the end of the
day
uh yeah i i actually got called in
to like well i showed up at the very end
to be like rock it's all cool right like
you know dwayne remember when you did
the 70s show
the back of the day probably the
professor were friends so it's good
like i got called in at the end of it
but that i mean there was some crazy i
mean i thought somebody was going to get
killed on the kanye one because he took
off
and like jumped on top of a moving car
and like
i mean there were some that like were
borderline dangerous
i i guess the one question is to whether
or not you could be done today
is legal because we were right on the
edge of
like we always had a lawyer screaming at
us in the control room for every one of
these things
and so you know now i mean people a
little more litigious
it might not be able to go off a couple
more minutes left here with ashton
kutcher
uh on the anniversary of punk a lot of
bears fans think they are being punked
right now by the
signing of andy dalton are you one of
them ashton kutcher
are you talking about the orange rifle
that's the one
that one i mean here's the thing like
i yeah my my mom always told me when i
got to the dinner table you get what you
get and you don't get upset
right so you know i'm looking at andy
dalton
and i'm like i always try to find like
the good side of it um you know one
we we have a first round a second round
a third round
fifth round i think like a fifth round
seventh round draft pick next year
and so you know we didn't have to give
up
the world right and and if we if we
would have got russell wilson
it sounds like that deal would have
meant giving up
the giving up the franchise we need an
offensive
line like we need we need depth in our
offensive line like daniels went down
last year
and it was obvious like we it's why we
had a good run at the beginning of the
season and it
fell off is that we we're playing the
offensive line shuffle game all year and
because we just don't have the depth
there so
i'm happy that we've got some draft
picks
i'm happy that we still have some you
know powder in the chamber
and look if you look at dalton like
through his career
you know i i think last year like
he he's always hovered around like a
60-plus percent completion
rate and and that's good
news right because you know truvisky
went under pressure couldn't hit the
broad side of a bar
um so i'm excited to have a guy that can
deliver the
deliver the football on target um and
you know
other than like that his last year in
cincinnati
it was kind of like he knew he was out
the door and it was kind of
ugly he's had he he's played
well um and we got robinson we got the
franchise tag
on what and miller is great and
and mooney is you know a really
promising young talent yeah so he's got
some receivers so maybe we can get an
offensive line
and our defense is dope so and we have a
new defensive coordinator that's
that's a little you know i we'll see
he's been he's been with the franchise
for a while he's a safety coach but
what you know i i actually think it's a
smart move
um all in all given you know we can get
russell wilson but
he'd probably get hurt if we can't
bolster our offensive line to keep him
keep him upright and then and then
you've spent all your draft picks and
all your money
on a guy who's just got hurt because he
couldn't protect it
all right so you're you're you're you're
being positive about it and i appreciate
the glass half full right there and um
you know and our radio audience is going
to be going away in about 30 seconds
time and
uh we'll continue this conversation on
our peacock side for just a couple of
minutes before we say
uh farewell to ashton kutcher but we we
do have uh
a segment here ashton called higher
register where we have to kind of go up
here in order to believe what we're
saying you did start a little higher
register about andy don't like hey you
know i mean he's got that sixty percent
completion present like he did go a
little higher register on me there
ashton uh you know listen is this the
guy for the future of the organization
i i don't know but i also don't think
that we're picking up a guy in like the
what the
11th year of his career and
thinking that this is the guy for the
future of the organization
so you know he might be a guy that can
can that he he's a guy that gives us a
shot
i know and we're back an hour three in a
second but sure yeah i i know i i hear
what you're saying
you know and i i just i i i like your
moxie i like your your positive thinking
ashton i just like it it's it's very
it's how i get through life rich
it's how you it's how you do it okay so
what do you think ten wins
for the bears you think they actually
threatened the packers
what do you think what do you got for me
oh man
um i got you know what i got
i have to look at the schedule i'm not
just going to throw it out there i i
really need to look at this
well it's coming out that's kind of so
you got a few more weeks and then maybe
as i was saying before ashton and i'll
just match your positive for positive
before uh sending you off onto your
wednesday um
that uh that if they draft somebody 20th
overall as a rookie
what better quarterback room than having
foals and dalton to show them the ropes
to not only show them about how to be a
professional but how competition can be
healthy
with two awesome human beings in the
room so
maybe that's something you can look at
by the end of april you know
i would like to dre i would like to get
some offensive
line love in let's build that up for a
year
they say we've got dalton for two and
then go for a quarterback
long game all right very good hey ashton
thanks for the time today
uh uh strolling down memory lane and you
know uh um
we we uh we're thrilled to be able to
know what you've known a very long time
it's just how awesome tj jefferson is
and what a great uh
what a great person he is and how much
fun he is to be around and
and just like a lair just keep on
layering all the layers of tj jefferson
every single day
you know listen he was he was my
co-pilot in
in in our fantasy football sports show
that we did for years he and i well i
think we did like three seasons
and so i knew that i knew he was
destined to be doing this so
i'm i'm stoked that that he's doing it
with you outstanding yeah and
soon he'll be above the fold in his
hometown newspaper right up in altoona
he's just below the fold with us
maybe together you and i ash and we can
get him above the fold of the hometown
altoona newspaper
winning win when he wins price is right
[Applause]
yes
yes cliffhanger all the way through to
the showcase showdown
i believe in him thanks for the call
ashton take care
you be well take care guys all right
that's ashton kutcher right here on the
rich eisen show
we're all up in your business tj yeah
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here